ready to talk about your motions not
really
every got no guy has been excited to
talk to me about their feelings as a man
do you feel comfortable expressing
yourself emotionally not at all no but
sometimes yeah I feel come to expressing
myself when I'm mad but not like
emotionally like like oh no feelings no
yeah yeah yeah totally feel comfortable
ah yes
sometimes it depends on the emotion
Tristan's a cancer he told me this so it
makes a lot of sense because of the man
I am a man of trans experience I
actually oddly feel more comfortable
expressing myself as a man than I did
before I transitioned I felt like I had
nothing to prove and and I could be as
emotional as I wanted to be I think it's
the fear of like being like vulnerable
so you would say like like crying you
would you know I don't cry in front of
you when was the last time you cried
probably like a year ago yeah I don't
remember the last time I cried have you
cried this year at all do you think
you've cried this year I I don't I don't
know I don't think so
tense [ __ ] I'm gonna cry I'm stoic as
[ __ ] I don't care it's like I
intellectualize everything when I cry I
almost like me didn't cry ugly cry but
that's okay cuz you humans out no one I
just want that like I want day that one
Diaz one hug here Darren with a flag
here oh I cried when I went to Hong Kong
for six months that was 2010 is not it's
like not okay to feel vulnerable so I'm
already conditioned so since I was a kid
that men do not cry mm-hmm so in the
problem with that is now I have a
problem being vulnerable in front of
people
professor ad bingo hopes of Tober
university studies crying and has found
that women cry on average a thirty to
sixty four times a year compared to men
who cry a three to four times a year B 6
to 17 times a year C 8 to 10 times a
year or D 5 to 8 times a year you know
I'm a buddy 3 to 4 if we're going based
off of like what men say I'm gonna say 5
day times a year probably 8 to 10 I'm
live there yes and it is 6 17 times a
year what's wrong with me yeah I believe
that I think it's more than that they
probably cry more but don't don't cop to
it or they like black it out or they
don't think of it as like crying last
year was the last time you nothing to
tell you
true or false this 1999 study of 81
participants from Harvard Medical School
in Boston Children's Hospital found that
6 month old boys were more emotive than
girls
I say true I would say true I'm gonna
say true you is a right there I knew
there no yeah buddy I'm a 3 year old boy
was under Maine that guys like so
emotional a 2011 study from the
University of Missouri found that boys
do not discuss feelings because a they
are afraid to talk about their feelings
B they think it will make them look weak
see they are biologically wired to not
feel the need to express emotions or D
they don't think it's useful I would say
be definitely be they don't think it's
useful well you should've went with your
gut cuz it's actually D yeah Rocco yeah
that's how I feel I'm like a chairs
right up on the study was that men are
more likely to think talking about
problems will make the problems feel
bigger than what they are so instead of
talking about them they'll engage in
activities to take their mind off 11
that's definitely not me for me is just
like I don't want to look weak the same
study also said that women have a
bit of over talking their feelings that
can produce more anxiety and stress so I
know what you're talking about
oh really dude emotions aren't burning I
don't got time for this I feel like we
need to learn how to cultivate a world
in which it's not necessarily being a
burden but it's like you know I care
about you and I want to make sure you're
doing the best and I want to yeah and I
just want us both to be able to equally
communicate that to each other you know
how do you think that we can move
towards that kind of world like
especially for men uh that promote
promote self care more I think it's
important for men and for anyone who's
struggling with a moding to know that
it's not a sign of weakness I think we
gotta continue raising our kids and
telling them hey listen it's okay to cry
it takes courage I love a good cry like
a nice like because then you just get it
all out all that pent-up energy in
emotion yeah yeah shake up it's not
break it up